not because of my surveillance so much
but because of those surveillance that
my clients have been under I have
completely had to change the way that I
work as a lawyer I basically use drug
dealer tactics I meet in person I pay in
cash and i use burner phones I have
multiple computers including an
air-gapped computer that's not hooked up
to the internet so that i can use
encrypted communications if we're not
able to meet in person for example with
Edward Snowden but again this is a very
cumbersome way to have to practice the
law that I should be able to send an
email to in a client a client and it
should be attorney-client privileged but
it's not like the NSA has a big carve
out for email between attorneys and
clients and given the nature of the
offenses my clients are being charged
with espionage I have to assume that
they're being surveilled and a number of
them are under obvious surveillance